can I ask you about uh are you still do
you still talk to Colby Covington yes a
lot uh yeah yes yes what's what's going
on with him is he gonna fight hamzat is
he is going up to middleweight the word
on the street yes that's right is that
confirmed by the way do you have that
confirm okay because I'm hearing the
same rumors yeah
the talk is
Gap together two best wrestlers that's
right with you yes that Colby will do
that fight but it's got to be a number
one Contender ship and that has been
something that's very unclear where they
just can't promise him that with the
thought that if Kamar uzman regains the
championship putting Colby against
Kamara third time they just can't commit
to it and Kobe's like look if you want
me to anybody else fights Jeremiah and
beats him they're going to be a number
that you know fight for the title you
got to give me the same thing or call
somebody else and he's not wrong to say
that I mean that pot just a little bit
yeah he does deserve it he is the
clearest number one Contender that there
is but there's more to the stories had a
couple of cracks at it so but he's a big
draw too yeah you can't do Covington
newsmon three I don't think so nobody
could do Leon Edwards Covington sure
well yeah of course yeah
sure that's happening in London oh
um yeah it's for sure I've been it
wasn't the it was a question mark
whether it Usman could fight because I
believe he had a surgery on his hands on
his hand but he's apparently recovered
and they're scheduled and they're
fighting in in London
um
which is great but yeah you can't do
Covington newsmon three like Covington
hamzat God that would be great
especially with Covington calling him
but you see where that'd be frustrating
if Colby goes and finds shamaya it's
gonna be very obvious that if tremaya
wins he gets to fight for the belt so
Colby's gonna but I gotta have the same
thing yeah um and you see what the
problem is I think you hit it on the
head which is hey you've already tried
twice we're just not gonna do a number
three I think everybody here understands
because everybody else is coming from is
there a dollar amount that it makes
sense to where it's like all right I
won't fight for the title if you offer
me yeah
that would have
to have you man if
an Usman 2 was a closer match than
Covington Usman won but it was not the
the first one was a very close match the
second one was not close at all so that
really ruins the three and you can't
even do a three anyway when it's not a
rubber mat yeah but I agree with that
well it's not a true Trilogy Where you
flip them well can you say that Usman
does now have that you know his Chin's
not so strong and it's a different story
after a fighter gets knocked out like
that there's an argument there that no
great promoter is ever gonna make right
yeah they're my Champions got a
compromise chin
up and buy your tickets now yeah I hear
your point though it just seems as
though and I do hope that uh live goes
to 185 I just think that's the right
move his life in general will be better
you know trying to beat that scale
that'll in careers people really don't
realize that what goes into beating that
scale today before but I mean that that
is where the longevity of your career
starts to diminish yeah back to Colby
Covington yeah we I love coldly dude
he's fantastic I've said this so so
often that I'm just
so invested in disliking him sure he's
just he he's he's
masterful at making you dislike him and
then and like with Jake Paul within
anybody who's uh in this digital age
it's it doesn't matter if it's positive
attention or negative attention it's
just attention is the most valuable
commodity known to man Colby Covington
is masterful like getting attention
albeit very negative attention
um you being
the original
trash talker guy you know like you were
the first like right I mean was there a
a prolific trash talker in MMA before
you no no that was an art that you uh
brought over from from wrestling for
sure yeah and since you like clearly
McGregor was the you know became the
prolific trash talker
and then there's coffee
I mean uh again it's effective I'll
never miss a call because sure I'll
never miss any fight I'm I'm uh I'm
addicted to to the sport
um but uh
what are your thoughts it's about trash
talk in general like
I have my I have my own views on it um
but but I had a code and I stuck
fiercely to the code I was called by
Sports illustrator the biggest [__]
talker in All Sport but I had never used
a four-letter word never you'll never
find anything public written or audio
I've never used a profanity and that was
one of the things I would never want to
after anybody unless they were in front
of me if I ever did go after somebody I
would always show up whether I felt good
or not I would I would go to that ring
and answer for it so I mean I just had I
had my own little code and I had two
different jurisdictions uh threatened to
not give me a license I had a guy named
Kaiser out of Nevada who said that uh
that I am not an example for little kids
and I was really thinking of going Keith
I've never used a bad word like you've
got what are you what are you talking
about but yes because of my my trash
talking and I only say it because it
wasn't all that bad it was just it was
the first it was way ahead of the time
for its time and it did catch people off
guard it was just a meaningfully a
difference opinion A lot of people
thought that respect was about bowing to
someone's face and putting a knife in
their back when they turned around I
will tell you to your face I'm gonna put
a knife in your back when you turn
around and there's a big difference
one's honorable but I thought mine was
more honorable so you know you reach for
years and I'll reach for one let's see
who's fastest but there's no sense in
hiding this and you know I appreciate
that about Colby I know that his is a
little bit different and he is a little
bit rougher at times but I do appreciate
that that he can take the booze and if
you're a heel if you're the bad guy Boos
are a heels cheers and you don't have
very many heels because they can't take
the booze they say they want it they
want the checks they want the placement
on the cart but they can't take the heat
they just can't they can't take it in
their real life you know these are I'm a
tough guy they're not all that tough
they're really sensitive and Colby's
able to take he's able to take the hits
and someday he will be looked back on
and people appreciate what he did but
for right now it's probably a pretty
lonely path
man that that that's so rad that's so
well said
um man it was kind of like when we had
Ronda Rousey on the podcast it made
headlines and it was negative headlines
and then we called her like [__] is that
and she's like dude are you kidding me I
love this [__] I'm the heel sure like
the more the merrier you know and it was
like a different perspective like oh
[__] like there's levels remember that
well I was like oh man gosh like I
didn't want to bummer out there's
backfire on you and [__] and she's like
are you kidding me I'm [__] gardening
making headlines yeah yeah
it's fantastic man so what's next for a
channel
soon to be can I throw one at you guys
that uh car McGregor I I am a bit of an
advocate for Conor I feel like I'm in a
big brother role where he goes and does
something I have to come and explain it
to the audience but he took such a bad
rap in his last fight just to remind you
guys he he breaks his way right there
yeah he's down on the canvas Joe Rogan's
down you know interviewing him and
Connor's yelling about to you know the
wife somebody slipping in my DMs so
people tell you know what a jerk he was
and what a bad guy and I said okay maybe
maybe that's what you saw or maybe you
just saw a performer so committed to
entertainment that even broken in half
before they faded a black and rolled the
credits he gave you everything that you
tuned in for and more you know there you
might not understand where the real
Masters are at work here and you know if
you don't see that you want a blue guy
you want to hate a guy go ahead but
there's also something that I think that
you should appreciate I don't know which
one it was maybe Conor was showing us
the real him and maybe he's a real jerk
but maybe he's not and maybe he was so
committed to the performance that he
played it until you know until the ship
went down and I think that that should
be considered because I hear Ron I know
people like to say the right things Iran
is at home crying herself to sleep none
of that stuff's real you just try to let
her know Rhonda these are good things
these are positive and good things and
every now and then you'll get her to
come and repeat it well I created an
emotion and that's like no but it really
is f them if they're booing it doesn't
matter if if they like you or they don't
like you is good if they have if they're
indifferent for you you have a problem
and I know that some of the heels can
come out and repeat that but they don't
actually mean it they're at home crying
in a bottle of wine and that that's much
more the real Rhonda the real masters of
their craft are the ones like Colby
that'll sit there with a broken leg and
finish this thing out
yeah
um well are there rules to being the
heel because people were like you don't
you don't say anything about you know
his wife or then Kobe and uh Jorge mask
with all he brought up the kids or
George around jail George is
it Jorge officially because I want to be
right is it Jorge I'll switch to Jorge
are there rules that you should stay in
or is it all uh uh you know no holds
bars when it comes to trash talking I
just think whatever I think I think if
you're gonna be an anti-hero one of the
things that that all great anti-heroes
will have is they will have a code it
won't be society's codes it won't be
laws it won't be a normal person's code
but it will be a code and they will
fiercely adhere to the code now this is
the art of the bad guy not very many
people are good bad guys and this
includes in Hollywood not very many
people are good or being a bad guy but
if you're going to be a good bad guy
you've got to have a code you've got to
advertise to the audience what it is and
you must fiercely adhere to it no matter
what you must defend it with an honor
that's the kind of guy that's the kind
of a heel that the crowd will get behind
to be a cool heel is the most guaranteed
monetizable box office that you can have
that would be the rock that would be
Stone Cold Steve Austin by example to be
a bad guy and be a cool bad guy and most
don't understand that because they never
lay out what their code is and if you're
if you've got a code and you're a bad
guy so you're telling Society I don't
need to follow your rules here's a
better set of rules you've got to
advertise what it is and if you go off
script and at no point in there was
going after a kid's family or his child
if that wasn't part of your code then
you've broken your own rules and now
you're not just a you're not a bad guy
you're a bad guy and there's a
difference do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butt hole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude